well look at you
may your dreams bring you peace in the
time
this is just funny it's not bad or good
that part's up to you
I don't mean to be rude I supposed to
know you actually me we just met
Oh
beep
it's harsh world strong prayer in the
week down here
yeah
does it bother you that I'm not
completely human
whatever I had to you for you I'd give
you whatever I have
I'd give you my heart Alida
they will come for you
why
I think you're someone very special mais
de
of the
I have seen gods fly I've seen men build
weapons that I couldn't even imagine
I've seen aliens drop from the sky yeah
never seen anything like this how much
my ID
we are home
my son it is your time
you get to decide what kind of King you
are going to be
don't freeze I never freeze
respect in bow down
right now cuz we
I waited my entire life for this the
world's gonna start over I'm a burn at
all what happens now determines what
happens to the rest of the world
would you look at that it seems like we
have ourselves a finished painting so
from our family to yours keep your pants
dry your dreams went and remember hugs
not drugs
can you describe its fall no start from
the beginning what do you think I do
when you're away you think I'm out in
the garden pining looking at the sky why
are you here I gotta leave a day early
your husband's here let me see him he's
extremely ill you have to tell me where
he was what he was doing it was his
decision to go in
it's something they termed the shimmer
they've sent in drones in teams of
people but nothing comes back but
something has you're a biologist who
served in the military if I knew what
happened I could save his life
the boundary is getting bigger it's
expanding we're talking cities States
you need to know what's inside it's
beautiful
check this out it's like they're stuck
in a continuous mutation are they
understand they're no sharks have teeth
like that not possible you can't cross
great different spaces yes the soldiers
on the last expedition they went crazy
or something here kill them something's
come to the fence or the fence
we have to go back I can't go back
we can camp here tonight
it's destroying everything it's not
destroying
it's making something new
there was an idea to bring together a
group of remarkable people to see if we
could become something more so when they
needed us we could fight the battles
that they never could
in time you will know what it's like to
lose feel so desperately that you're
right
yet to fail all the same
read it
run so much
Dustin's still alive
evacuate the city
engage our defenses
and get this man a sheet
fun isn't something one considers from
balancing the universe
but this does put a smile on my face
the hell are you guys
we're running out of time you've seen
what's happening out there
I can handle Thomas show up eventually
that's what I'm afraid of
they took you because you're immune
a plague that's wiping out the human
race they think you're worth sacrificing
to find a cure but every stop totally
stop them the last City vertical base of
operations mr. Lyons dinner bottle HP
we're going three years we spent behind
walls trying to break out now we're
trying to break back in all right I
guess Shaka
the world is dying
if we find a cure that's the only way
all this was worth it to regret are you
just us
I did what I thought was right there's
no guarantee we make it back from this
don't we stop this together
there's where I'll end it that way too
you still care about it don't you lie to
me
I'm gonna Cates believe the roundup
torture kill when how does it stop it
stops holy find a cure
Thomas you can save your friends or you
can save us all
please
we were born into a world at war between
the monsters that destroyed our cities
and the monsters we created to stop them
we thought we had sacrificed enough but
the wall we thought we finished is just
beginning and the only thing standing in
front of the apocalypse
is us
but it doesn't matter where you came
from who believed in you and who did it
this is our time this is our chance to
make a difference
let's get it done
my ball
the Lara
they evolve and they could wipe out all
life
there's something you need to see
well he's pretty big
by everything you got
so uh what are you dating like an
accountant our owen ventriloquist stop
you love a dummy this is not why we're
here
you can blame
try to show me I know why we're here a
rescue op save the dinosaurs from Island
that's about to explode what could go
wrong
blue is alive you raised her do these
animals deserve the same protections
given to other species or should they
just be left to die these creatures were
here before us and if we're not careful
they're gonna be here after
you know
life cannot be contemned life breaks
free life finds away
my name is Wade watts my dad picked that
name because it sounded like a
superhero's alter-ego like Peter Parker
or Bruce Banner but he died when I was a
kid my mom too and I ended up here
sitting here my tiny corner of nowhere
there's nowhere left to go nowhere
except the Oasis
a whole virtual universe
people come to the Oasis for all the
things they can do they stay because of
all the things they can be can you feel
this
yeah the only place that feels like I
mean anything
the Oasis was the brainchild of James
Halliday oh if you're watching this I'm
dead
I created a hidden-object an easter egg
the first person to find the egg will
inherit half a trillion dollars and
total control of the Oasis itself
who is this possible and how the hell is
he winning find him this is just a game
I'm talking about absolute
life-and-death stuff the Oasis the
world's most important economic resource
it's nothing less than a war for control
of the future
welcome to the rebellion wait
I only came here to escape
but I found something much bigger than
just myself
are you willing to fight
helped us save the oasis
what is that that is London
it's weird you like hang out with
animals more than people yeah
well animals get me a rescue George he
was 2 years old
George never would have survived on his
own he definitely trusts you last night
George was seven feet away 500 pounds
George you okay buddy you're scared it's
okay this morning his nine feet pushing
a thousand what's happening to my friend
familiar with genetic editing changes
will be incredibly unpredictable is he
the only one oh you didn't know about
the 30-foot wolf hello the day huh
science experiments falling from the sky
having George on that plane it's big
mistake
I think we'll be all right
let's go save the world
it's coming back to me
you have to evacuate Chicago George
didn't ask for this they're gonna put
them down
that's not happening
Oh
there's something in the river I was
just thinking the only thing that's
missing right now is the giant crocodile
you